we got uh jenna i wonder if this is the
same jenna that i had on with sterling
cooper
uh she says i honestly wish men would
work harder on developing an identity
all right jenna what do you got for me
hey rich it is me that is the same one
how you doing not too bad how you doing
sir good good so what do you got for me
tonight here
um i was actually just sitting here with
a glass of macallan and watching
yellowstone and then i looked and you
were live and
i was thinking about have you ever seen
the show oh yeah yeah it's a great show
amazing show i would really suggest you
guys watch it um
what i'm finding why would you suggest
that these guys watch it if you can be
specific because
um because i know why i watch it oh yeah
um
i think it's it's the fact that it's the
number one show on amazon should tell
you that the world is actually telling
you about manhood in a way that is
counterproductive they're telling you
they want you to be more feminine but
it's the number one show on amazon and
it's nothing but masculinity it's a show
about cowboys that like
bare knuckle beat the out of each
other hardcore i'm not gonna spoil it
for you every episode watch it trust me
it's in and also it shows you what
manhood looks like correct
um
the reason i said that in the chat that
i think men should focus more on their
identity is two things one
for those of you who watch the show you
get to see the contrast between casey
which is one of the sons who's like a
former military guy who has integrity
and dignity
john dutton the father who's like the
typical patriarch and jamie who's the
cowardly son and jamie is what a lot of
guys accidentally become when they take
your talking points and they don't
actually take the time to interpret them
properly so for example
a couple uh probably last year i
actually went out on a date with a guy
who turned out to be a follower of yours
okay and
it was so unfortunate because he
mentioned your name and he literally
told me that i needed to it was
something along the lines of staying in
his frame or i need to
um he used some of the language that you
use verbatim and it was so unfortunate
because i did it wrong he did it
completely wrong so what he did so
reason i say that is
identity is one of the most important
things that a man can have because you
just end up becoming whatever you need
to become in the moment to get what you
want but you don't become anything other
than that and you end up becoming a very
feckless cowardly person like jamie
like if anyone who's watched the show
you know that jamie the son literally
just goes with whatever everybody else
says he doesn't actually interpret
what's going on around him so for the
people who are followers of you
um
listen to what rich is saying i don't
agree with everything that rich is
saying but i understand there's so many
men that need guidance i think it's
lovely that you're saying it but at the
same time listen to what he's saying but
learn to interpret
learn to learn to apply it to your
circumstances or your situation without
regurgitating it you just become a
parent and girls because we know about
like the manosphere we can tell that
you're doing that and there's nothing
more pathetic than looking at a dude and
going you got your identity off of
youtube right yeah i shouldn't know i
shouldn't know that you follow this
channel you don't try to lecture women
on the red pill guys you don't try to
tell her to be in your frame
you you act the part you
you you become it okay
and it's just communicated to her
by way of your choices your actions your
availability in your schedule all of
those things if you see what i'm saying
and to the point of yellowstone as
jenna's talking about it she mentioned
jamie there's another character in the
series her name's beth which happens to
be jamie's sister
jamie's sister
runs him into the ground
she is
she's basically kryptonite to the guy
she doesn't know like he doesn't know
how to handle it right and she despises
him because he's a weak man and all of
these characters in the show like you'll
come to understand it if you watch it i
know some of you guys watch it and some
of you have never heard of it but it's
worth checking out jenna's making a good
point with that
yeah oh sorry um i just had one more
thing to say
um for those of you who don't have
good relationships with women or haven't
had good relationships with your mothers
or whatever the case may be
um you really need to make a conscious
effort to to to kind of keep in mind
that some of you are actually turning
into the person you despise
i've encountered that as well men who
have had issues i've i met a guy who's
actually police officer he told me flat
out his mother was a ho
um that she was she was loose when he
was a child and every woman now has to
prove to him that she's not you know
some horrible whatever
if you have a problem with women
it's something that you need to work out
because the same guy or another guy can
have the same interaction with that
woman and get completely different
results it means you're applying
something wrong to that situation or you
lack discernment you can't stop and
assess
which woman is good for you and you're
counting on the woman to be the person
who tells you
what is best for you and that's not
that's not really how you function as an
adult
correct
thanks jenna no worries have a good one
take care bye
you